independent filmmakers don't even know
about this stuff this is stuff that's
totally foreign that they would never
get around to they don't have enough
time to get around to it let alone to do
it
even if they knew about it
what's different about the pitching
process with netflix now versus prior
years 2015 2014.
like i said before it's bigger company
so they generally they generally don't
take pictures that's a different
you know
i've done business with netflix for
three films but i'm not going to call
myself a netflix expert there are people
who do way more business than i do
especially different types of business
like internally you know i haven't done
any netflix originals i've talked to
them about it
um there's a different department and
different style and all that kind of
stuff so i just sort of know what i know
as an outsider and again i'm not i guess
i'm much further ahead than any indie
filmmaker who hasn't done any business
with them but
like i feel like i'm not that qualified
to talk about it but i guess more so
than others but
the pitching you know what makes it
different i mean it's just uh
back then i mean they took pitches they
just don't take them they don't have the
time or the interest
unless it's it's done through you know
the right channels which is agents or
distributors so it's you're basically
locked out now
how are your pitches different now
knowing that they're a bigger company
they have less time they have so many
people trying to get into that front
door yeah
my pitches to everybody not just netflix
anybody who i'm dealing with are shorter
and more concise and right to the point
because of lack of time and they hear so
much
so i get right down to it
one it's almost a log line like here's
the movie here's what it's about
and here's the audience and here's how
we're going to go after that audience
and here's what i'm going to bring to
the table as a result here's the
marketing i'm going to do and it's
like i say i try to keep it to five
minutes
and then the rest is hopefully questions
um but that's all you really need
you can get to i could do it in 20
probably 30 seconds
but i spread it out just a little bit so
i'm not talking too fast
but yeah back then i was pitching as i
said in the last video you know i would
do 20 to 30 minutes for a pitch tell
them about the story tell them about
this the actors how we're going to shoot
and they don't care nobody cares about
that stuff just make a darn good movie
tell us who the audience is and and you
know deliver
so if i was at netflix you've just just
pitched me
um
what are my questions going to be to you
or am i just sending you out the door
thank you very much we'll look it over
no but remember i'm not going to get a
pitch for something that i'm unless it's
a netflix original and and in that case
i'm sort of just telling them the idea
and that's more about the script because
they're just basically going to buy the
script and maybe hire me to make the
film or maybe just take the script and
make it internally with one of their
crews
so you know potentially i could be hired
on you know maybe just direct or
something
and then we would talk it's all artistic
it's not about audience anymore because
they're going to own the film they'll
control that they'll bring all that to
the table
so the other flip side is pitching a
finished film you've already finished
the film so you don't have to talk about
the story or this or that so back then
i would do that now i don't talk about
any of that because here's the film like
just watch the film i don't have to tell
you what like that's why i say it's
one sentence about the log line you know
but but here's the film you either want
it or you don't want it based on the
movie itself
so they're hearing the log line they're
taking the materials maybe they'll
they're watching it
and then they'll watch the movie for
sure no no unlike distributors they'll
definitely watch the movie no i mean
they don't watch every movie they'll
watch the first 10 minutes and if they
like it then they'll watch the next 10
minutes and hopefully they get through
the whole thing right to make sure that
it's okay
but the reason that they'd be interested
is because there's a audience attached
to it
because there's like i say
if i if i had 10 seconds to pitch
netflix on and that's all you got right
maybe i should suggest this to netflix
give every indie filmmaker 10 seconds
you know speed pitching right or 20
seconds or something like that
i wouldn't even tell them the name of
the film all i'd say is i have 2 million
viewers on youtube who've already seen
it and want to see it on netflix
that's the pitch
hopefully that's the case
and they'd say oh by the way what's the
name of the film
you sure you got the 2 million prove to
us she got the 2 million let's see it
did you dig it did you do something
that's the pitch
i mean you know the film matters
but the audience matters more
can we reenact the pitch that you did
for your last movie
sure to netflix how did you let's
suppose i'm the person on the other side
of the desk
great to see you have a seat you know
can you get them some water coffee great
thank you no that didn't even happen
that happens in the long run they
validate your bathroom that's happens in
the lobby they have a nice station in
the lobby go get yourself a drink a
coffee whatever and no when we get up to
the meeting room let's get right into it
all right so the pitch was very simple
it was like
i want to make another
the the olympics are coming in two years
um i believe that we did well with our
first movie with full out and i would
like to make another gymnastics movie
similar to that because with the
olympics coming we know that women's
gymnastics is a big thing in an olympic
year
and you've already developed that
audience with the first movie would you
be interested in having another one and
i've already got a story and i got an
idea of who we would do it with it would
be very similar to the first one but a
you know completely different storyline
but
it would engage the exact same audience
and i think that it would be the timing
would be good to deliver it then
during that olympic year similar to what
we did with the first one
and what was their response
i like it we like it what tell me more
and the more right there in the meeting
okay the answer was yeah that's a good
idea okay what are you thinking i'm
thinking we should do
this this storyline i know it came
a minute
um i've got this gymnast you know
um who who did this
and i think it'd make a really good
story and instead of doing hip-hop
dancing i want to do break dancing in
this one so similar type of thing with
two characters that meet
but let's go into the break world
because it's really cool these days and
the music is really good and i think
that'll resonate
okay great idea
when when you wanted to shoot it blah
blah blah i'm gonna shoot it then when
would you deliver okay we would need it
by here by this time
and um
then the number
then
how much would you be willing to pay
and then we get into that
and that takes
a minute or two
no but they also by the way they're
sitting with an ipad and they're saying
oh let's see what did fallout 1 do
yeah okay the numbers look pretty good
all right let's talk about the next one
they would actually give you that number
oh no they don't tell you they they're
looking at their ipad they're not
telling you they're saying yeah okay
looks okay we're good we're good to go
next
i say can you share the not can you turn
the ipad around i want to see the
numbers no we don't do that
you know it would be really good i i put
some of my heart and soul into it can't
you just
you know throw me a bone here tease me
give me one number sorry we don't do
that you know we don't do that and they
don't do that that's their proprietary
information and that's the way it works
but
luckily the numbers were good on that
ipad otherwise the conversation would
have been really short
and so
this was less than a 10-minute meeting
this last one the substance was 10
minutes there might have been five
minutes of pleasantries okay how are you
doing
you know how's the golf game nice office
whatever you know yeah but yeah yeah it
took about 10 minutes but there was one
other piece of business in that movie
because i was wanting to do a renewal on
the first one too it was coming up for
renewal and so
we were talking about both the renewal
and the next one
i see okay yeah and the numbers were
good so both happened the renewal and
the the new one
so that works in your favor obviously so
you go in there with good numbers and
then you pitch them something else it's
everything if the numbers aren't good
it's over
it's over before it starts
yeah i mean there's nothing to talk
about
i mean getting the first one is the
tough one because you don't have any
numbers the second one if your numbers
are good it's real easy meeting and if
your numbers are bad it's a very tough
meeting you got to explain why your
numbers are going to be better the next
time around if they're even interested
to hear it but the subject matter is
super niche i know that audience really
well i've done tons of marketing to it i
they know i'm connected to it they know
that i know how to get to that audience
and create viewership there
so because i've already done the
marketing and now even more so we're
gonna like you know and i explain what
we're gonna do in addition to this with
the dance world that we didn't do last
time so that's music to their ears and
hopefully it works and hopefully they
get new subscribers as a result of it i
mean i want them to be successful
because if they're successful then
hopefully they greenlight something else
i'm gonna do
and that's just supporting their efforts
how are you sharing your ideas for
marketing the film that you're pitching
so with netflix or with everybody i mean
let's see
for this
for this case yeah netflix oh i'm
telling them straight up i'm saying okay
we're going to start with the gymnastics
the usa gymnastics um which is their
network of all the gyms across the
united states and the coaches so we're
gonna we're gonna get an endorsement
from them
i had a special olympian in there so
we're going to you know special olympics
we're getting their endorsement meaning
they'll put the message out to all of
their athletes and families of which
they have many
um we i'm dealing with um
the dance magazine and dance world so
there's all kinds of um dance tons of
dance clubs um and studios and so i'm
advertising through them i'm doing both
paid advertising and social media and
then we're doing some a whole bunch of
of
web-based stuff with one of our key
dancers so
the main breakdancer in the movie is a
world-renowned breakdancer and so she
did interactive stuff that we had all
planned pre-planned as part of the
promotion
um and so they don't know anything about
the breaking world
i didn't know much about it either i
learned about it obviously but um so as
i explained it to them and they looked
up you know who this is and what these
communities are and how to get to them
and everything like that and you know
that's probably a good audience for them
and they probably have a lot of that
audience already but you know it's
interesting for for them to hear about
it so these are things that you know
you're explaining not in a ton of detail
just enough to you know tweak their
interests and make them see that you're
going to do some hard work and really
engage try to engage an audience and
that's for everybody's benefit primarily
for the benefit of my movie because i
want audience on it
by the way this is before they say yes
right so i'm doing this anyways
regardless of whether they say yes i'm
doing because i want to be successful
with my movie so if they don't say yes
you know maybe i take it to apple tv and
pitch them the same thing or to you know
to hulu or something like that which by
the way did so you know
i mean you know because you're waiting
six weeks you're not sitting there with
your thumb up your butt waiting for an
answer you're pitching everybody because
you
you know you hope that
somebody comes through and you hope it's
the one you want but it's kind of like
applying for
for lack of a better example college
you don't apply to one you apply to one
that's a disaster unless you're pretty
darn sure you're gonna get in you apply
to ten or you know and and you hope that
you know you're just hedging your bets a
little bit
so the long line is equally important as
how you'll market to your audience and
who your market who your audience is
it sounds like
neither is more important than the other
you've got to have both the log line is
just for pitching
you know i mean everybody on their
platform doesn't put just a log line
they put a synopsis you know you go into
netflix and you see a three or four
sentence synopsis on every film
um so the log line is just when you're
pitching it's the yellow it's what the
people call the elevator pitch thing
you know you got three floors in an
elevator and you better get it out
quickly so you just get a log line in
there that sort of captures what the
movie's about and then as soon as you
capture their attention then they might
ask you more details and you can go into
a little bit more detail
but i find by the way i find that
filmmakers the big mistake they make in
pitching and they do this all the time
when i'm consulting with them is they
talk way too much about the story
i mean we all know story elements we get
it we know genres i mean i know pretty
well all of them so
just like tell me the details because i
say to them this is the irony so they're
paying me
for their time you know they might book
an hour right and they're paying for
that and they start going into the story
and i say no no no let me stop here for
a second i don't want you wasting your
time your paid time telling me your
story i get it i get the audience i get
who you're talking about i don't need
the details of the story i'm sure it's
great i'm sure it's unique let's get
into the substance the substantive stuff
which is the marketing and the
distribution all that kind of stuff
because don't take 20 minutes to tell me
your story because they would otherwise
because they're so engaged in their
story and it's not about the story i
mean it's obviously at the end of the
day when you make the movies about the
story but it's not about the story at
that at that stage
that's why i was wondering is how
important it sounds like then the
synopsis or log line whatever it is
you're going off to pitch them is
equally important as
who's your demographic who how are you
getting to them well think about it like
you're sitting there you're netflix
buyer right i'm saying to you i'm going
after the dance world in the gymnastics
world
okay as long as i have a decent story
where there's characters and character
arcs and development and everything like
that i mean the question they need to
ask is how many dance routines am i
going to have how many gymnastics
routines am i going to have oh yeah
what's the main character and what's
their relationship but you know how many
big production scenes are going to like
kids want to see the gymnastics and the
dance that's what they really want to
see and as long as it's not a disaster
you know the rest of it you know it's
got to have a story that weaves through
and a compelling story line and like i
say character accent everything like
that but
but if you have all that and you don't
have good production like you don't have
any dance sequences or or gymnastics
competitions or something like that it's
not going to be a good movie for that
audience
so that's really what
if you understand who your audience is
and i understand my audience because you
know i make movies for them then i'm
saying to netflix this is what my
audience wants to see and they
understand that because they have shared
audience and they understand what
audiences like to see
fame tv show fame yeah for sure all of
the dance routines interwoven they had
they had cheer they had cheer on there
that sure was the series that they did
about cheerleading so they understand
that market really well
um but now that's in the department that
acquires that's the licensing side so
that's who i'm pitching to is they're
going to acquire the movie right if
you're pitching to netflix originals
where you're talking story this pitch
might be totally different it might be
way more about story character art plot
points all this kind of stuff i mean
they're going to get more into the
artistic side of it because
they're going to be making the movie
with you so they want to see some of the
artistic vision but this is you're
making a movie and you're going to tell
them why it's marketable and you're
hopefully going to make a good movie
that they're going to buy they're not
involved at all artistically
so it's a sort of a different style
altogether it's not sort of it is it is
you're not talking creatives with them
you're talking about audience that
you're going to resonate with when you
deliver this finished film the film's
done they have no say in it because it's
you can't change it it's over
whereas in the other side the netflix
original it's nothing's happened yet
they can change everything and you would
have a broader audience for this because
i'm thinking of like the tv show dance
moms i believe i've never actually
watched it just seen trailers but you
have not only the the
kids in the in the thing that are the
dancing the dancers sorry but um you
also have the the mom so you have a much
wider you have parents and you have
their kids oh yeah and i just told you
two components i went you know break
dancing and gymnastics of course there's
there's lots of ancillary stuff and
everything yeah no i have a whole
marketing plan i just didn't want to
spend too much time on this interview
talking about it but we could go into a
lot more detail
um you know about like all the
components of what we did i mean i did a
whole bunch of promotions too like for
example i'll just give you one
you know we shot that particular movie
we shot in oklahoma city
at the university of oklahoma with the
oklahoma sooners it's about one of their
gymnasts and it's shot on location there
so i did a huge promotion in oklahoma
city with pizza hut
you know and i created a lot of
awareness by doing a pizza top box
topper that goes out to you know i don't
know 50 000 pizzas they sell in whatever
period it was
um so that the local audience because
you know the girl's wearing a oklahoma
sooners outfit that's the key art so
everybody in oklahoma city knows who the
sooners are you might not know but
everybody there does from seeing your
movie yeah okay so
so that's local stuff yeah we also did
lots of television you know um publicity
spots there we got a lot of ads and not
ads but we got a lot of um spots on
local editorial public they were all
interested that a movie was being shot
on location about a true story about one
of their gymnasts so we got lots and
lots of that which i used in that market
more so i'm not going to use that
nationally because it doesn't resonate
but locally it resonates really well
so you know but the netflix of the world
understand all that stuff because their
business is engaging audiences so they
get something you know like some kansas
city reporter doing a story of you know
brennan dowell which is what happened
is great in kansas city and that's good
you know and what does that mean to
netflix it's one tiny component of their
entire
base but it's better than nothing
and maybe they can you know sign up ten
you know a thousand more subscribers
there in that marketplace based on that
maybe
this is micromanaging running a business
so you know and building your audience
no those are great details and i love
that and i love that you would think of
pizza hut maybe that's something that
but families are going to be ordering
pizza and who's going to want to see it
the pizza hut thing first of all there's
i should have brought it there's a whole
um flyer that we printed with a with a
um you know a discount on watching the
movie you get a so the reason pizza hut
was in was so the the win-win was
they stuck this flyer it was like a
postcard size thing of the graphic and
i'm saying new movie available you know
on the following platforms and it's like
you know six
transactional platforms and then the
flip side is special promotion from
pizza hut 50 off in this market with
this pizza and here's the code and you
stick it in and you get it for 30 days
you can watch the movie for half price
with the purchase of this pizza so it's
a win-win but hold on that was just one
i mean that's one promotion i do tons of
those and and pizza hut was just one of
the
there's 10 pizza chains so i pitched
like five of them not just pizza hut
i wanted pizza hut but if pizza had said
no you know maybe it was dominoes you
know i mean you're pitching everybody
but like i say i spend way more time
marketing than i do on making movies way
more time that's the kind of stuff
you're talking about and to kind of go
back to what i was talking about before
filmmakers first of all don't even know
about this kind of stuff secondly what
filmmaker wants to do that film like
talking to 10 pizza joints to figure out
a local pizza promotion you don't want
to do that you want to make movies
studios have all this built in they just
take for granted all that kind of stuff
independent filmmakers don't even know
about this stuff this is stuff that's
totally foreign that they would never
get around to they don't have enough
time to get around to it let alone to do
it
even if they knew about it like i'm
telling you like to me this is like a
no-brainer i'm talking about it it's
like that's nothing compared i can tell
you some way more niche stuff than that
like that is a pretty big promotion i
mean there's stuff that's even smaller
and you're saying wow that's interesting
and i'm thinking that's not that
interesting i mean that's kind of what
you do
how are you getting a mom and daughter
in chicago to care about
a gymnast from oklahoma
because hopefully the daughter's taking
gymnastics or dance and hopefully she's
connected to a gymnastics or a dance
club where her coach says hey this new
movie came out it's really nice family
fair i think you and your family would
enjoy it
and
potentially a little bit of social media
where we're targeting maybe facebook ads
that target to that you know depends on
how old the daughter is maybe she's 12
that's our core audience for that kind
of movie
and you know maybe they
facebook has all these analytics and
everything so you know that's part of it
um but yeah we're we're reaching out a
different
the more direct stuff is through the
clubs
and we send we send the clubs every club
got sent a postcard kind of similar to
what i was talking about every club to
the coach
when we did the first one if it wasn't
the pandemic because the clubs were
closed and the first one we sent a
poster to every club and asked them to
hang the poster
you know a sign poster was a nice really
nice poster so that was a nice sort of
thing to put in their lobby
you know um so and that creates
awareness and then of course we have a
website which they go to and get details
and that type of thing and that's
generic marketing i mean it's specific
to that audience but this is what i'm
talking about like
there's so much involved in marketing i
mean when you do marketing for a living
that's not that special what i just said
and it's special but not that special
but when you do filmmaking
all of a sudden marketing is like holy
smokes i didn't even know about this
stuff like this is this is really good
like i i didn't even know you could do
that kind of stuff yeah there's a
creativity in what you're telling me
because there's different things you can
plug in here and it's a challenge it
doesn't sound that easy there's
creativity in knowing what to do and
then there's execution and actually
doing it which is a lot of work if that
stuff doesn't come overnight you gotta
work it and you gotta negotiate it and
contract it and deliver and print and do
all this kind of stuff but you know when
it works it you can get really good
results